but a great win for us and I'm really
happy the referees didn't screw up the
clock at the end of the game so it was
great yeah I'm gonna enjoy it you know I
wish you know it makes me really upset
about the call at the end of last week
you know it really does I'm not gonna
let that go you know the TUC TUC rule
and that call last week I'm not saying
cost a second game but it was really bad
this is the team that when their backs
against the wall I mean they they come
out swinging and fighting and whatever
it takes you know sometimes it's not not
pretty and it doesn't have to be you
know and just put someplace together
score more points in our opponent holder
our bonus down and you know just just
play great team football as dr. Peters
any ghost ghost before that John Gurdon
Raiders coach who is only happy when
he's unhappy right a little bit out with
him yeah a little bit he likes what it's
like everybody doubts him against the
world he gets to be angry and he's the
mad scientist that's why he almost he
almost operates better that way and he
was referring to the loss at home to the
Jaguars the last game ever played in
Oakland the Raiders still alive and
they'd be in much better position to
steal the six seed yeah if they had
bring up the Tuck rule I mean at 17
years ago 1919 let's give it up let's
move on it's a it's 1818 it was 2001
yeah all right here you go you're ready
I'm ready out of the song determine the
Sunday statement draft a statement
drives undeath this one you can get it
you can get it common pressure who was
the last non division winner to reach
the Super Bowl last non division winner
to reach the Super Bowl see it I need
time to think about it cuz you got to
start working your way back okay well
you better hurry last non-division
wanted to win the Super Bowl the Packers
yeah okay no the joke was trying to take
my hand off the checker thank you very
much god bacon in recent years the one
seeds in the two seats have not been
losing in the division right on in the
passion is won the division in 2011 but
we're a wild card you know participants
yeah they beat they beat the Falcons the
Falcons at home zone play opting to to
write I want to say was 22 - yeah
right alright good thank you I get the
first pick no problem
not that there's an obvious number one
here but I have to go anytime Lamar
Jackson gets a double triple he's gonna
be on this list because it's amazing to
think that in the entire history of the
NFL and this double triple stat that MDS
came up with it's any category of yard
generation receiving rushing passing
kick return punt return fumble return
interception return anything the record
for a career is 8 that's Mike Vick Lamar
Jackson in less than two full seasons
already has 6 yeah and he has 5 this
year and yesterday was the latest where
he had 100 yards plus rushing and a
hundred yards are and 100 yards plus
receiving now 100 yards plus receiving
for a quarterback no big deal it's a
quarterback rushing for a hundred yards
and he's got five games this year with
100 more rushing yards and he's got
1,200 for the season that is incredible
for a quarterback and yeah I don't know
how many more yards he could have in a
season like next year what are we gonna
expect from Lamar Jackson 1,300 rushing
yards like is this the sweet spot is
this the high-water mark that he should
just hope to achieve but cuz you're
always trying to get better yeah how
does he do better than what he did this
year I hope it shouldn't be that next
year I hope not I mean they can't you
know again I do think you know at some
point it can't be about it but the
running sets up the pass does I just it
to me and he's it these the early part
of his career he's still young you can
get away with it but it can't be just
all about him to win the games you know
it's got to be a little bit of
everything else and then hey he can run
and keep you keep you honest that way
but either way I mean at some point his
career needs to transition to a pop
right he likes Steve or senior right but
it's still that threat of running the
ball even later in his career you see
Steve Young run from jacket on yeah you
need to have that threat that you're
gonna run the ball to keep the defense
on it that's right and and I think year
three four or five of his career we're
still in that area where Lamar Jackson's
gonna be running the ball a lot
yeah yes he is he's learning how to keep
himself healthy that's one thing that
John Harbaugh told me yesterday one of
the various things we talked about the
coaching points
Lamar is smart he understands he gets it
and he wants to protect himself and he's
figured that out remember Aaron Rodgers
told him in the preseason slide yeah we
saw him slide yesterday not take a hit
yeah we've seen a little bit more of it
lately of him taking care of his body
that way which is a good thing
especially for this little playoff run
here where the defenses are gonna be
better and more tuned into trying to
make him hurt when he does carry the
ball Doug Peterson is where I'm gonna go
I mean yeah you know just he's a
statement not the entire Eagles or doubt
just Doug Peterson yeah it's Doug
Peterson I'm gonna give him a lot of
credit here I mean just to continually
give the team a positive message message
they always seem to believe I mean it's
just the the you've said it a million
times that the ultimate backs against
the wall type of football team and
really they were not the more talented
team on the field yesterday but because
of Doug Peterson's gameplan and their
overall a plot approach as a full team
offensively and defensively they
outplayed a team that was more talent
than they are it didn't matter but he
had a formula and a plan of attack where
it was we're gonna run the ball we're
gonna control the clock it's gonna be a
lot of short you know five to eight yard
passes with an occasional shot down the
field this being one of them a little
wheel route by the slot receiver Ward
and then the defense of course you know
doing some outside the box things as
well but Doug Peterson just showing once
again that you know the Eagles are never
dead and you can never count them out I
didn't think they would win we met
yesterday there's no doubt about that
but between him and the confidence and
toughness he instills in the team and
then the way Carson Wentz is playing on
top of that that makes Billy scary again
here we go into week 17 and in the
playoffs yeah
just like two years ago just like last
year here come the Eagles and two years
ago they were the one seed but they
didn't have Carson Wentz and many
assumed that they would fall apart in
the playoffs and they didn't yeah and
they may end up with that home playoff
game and I don't know that you want to
be the five seed in the NFC going to
Philly in a single elimination so it's
scary on grass that crowd that stadium
they're you know they're big and
physical up front you know that's the
one thing too that we saw yes
today and we're seeing a little bit more
lately or Philadelphia is downhill
running there just kind of saying okay
we're just coming at you straight ahead
and we might only get three or four
yards but we're gonna take some time off
the clock
rest our own defense who's had some
issues and they're playing smart they're
playing good all-around football all
right my next one a guy who doesn't get
a whole lot of recognition because he
plays for a team that isn't all that
great but Chandler Jones oh good job by
Cardinals pass rusher who picked up four
sacks yesterday and if he does it again
this week not that four sack games are
just like hanging around the back alley
but if he does it again against the Rams
team that isn't playing for anything 23
would break Michael Strahan's
single-season record the the quietest
pursuit of a single-season record that I
can ever remember right and look he went
from 15 to 19 just like that so it's
gonna be a thing this week it's
something we got to pay attention to but
Chandler Jones now I think a real
candidate for Defensive Player of the
Year I know Stefan Gilmore has said he's
the Defensive Player of the Year and the
fact that he's on a playoff team may
give him a greater chance to get some
boats but if Chandler Jones sets the
record it's his yeah he gets four sacks
next week he's the Defensive Player of
the Year yeah I mean Chandler Jones I
don't know he's not yeah I mean if he
sets the record he is if he sets the
record the all-time single-season sack
record if he sets a good one to play a
good I'm thinking about I never really
thought about it
you're right I mean that would be tough
to argue because Stephon Gilmore
deserves to be the Defensive Player of
the Year as of right now without a doubt
from what he's done for that team and
that defense and what they do but
Chandler Jones would you get that record
I mean that I don't think that's special
you're right I guess the a little bit of
the relevancy of the the the Arizona
Cardinals probably hurts them there a
little bit but either way I get you he's
gonna be in the conversation if he
breaks the record alright I'm gonna give
a little love to the New York Giants and
Berkeley and Daniel Jones the future I
mean the future the dynamic duo on the
offensive side of the ball you know I
wanted to talk about Michael Thomas but
we talked about him a lot already we
know he made a statement he's the man I
just want to spread some love to some of
the other games but say qualm Barkley
and Danielle Jones yesterday if you're a
Giants fan how are you
pumped about what you saw I mean sake
want healthy explosive making
unbelievable plays not only in the run
game but the pass game too and then
Daniel Jones I just you know reminding
us in the little absence there when you
I came in that man Daniel Jones has got
some big-time Talent
he really does he just his ability to
stand in the pocket make good decisions
and really just striped throw after
throw into perfect spots so to me it's
really impressive he's got the demeanors
succeed in New York he's got the talent
to succeed in the NFL and then with him
and say qualm barkley into the future
and guys like darius Slayton who were
only a rookie and Evan Ingram's not even
out there the Giants have a young core
of skilled guys to be excited about yeah
I agree with you and between the two
guys I don't know who had a bigger day
yesterday day but it was very impressive
and it should worry the Philadelphia
Eagles on Sunday when they go to New
York to try to win the division because
the Eagles lose to the Giants and that's
all the motivation the Giants need if
the Giants win that game this could
still be the Cowboys winning the NFC
East all right last one for me yeah if
you're gonna leave I know we've talked
about Michael ties here's a question
because he had 12 catches and well over
100 yards and had a touchdown and we
talked already about how great he is and
how high this number can go Lamar
Jackson Michael Thomas not MVP Offensive
Player of the Year yeah because we've
seen in the past and we've seen a saint
in the past who has won Offensive Player
of the Year but not MVP and that's Drew
Brees right we have a record for Michael
Thomas an all-time record that had stood
for 17 years and he may put this thing
in a spot where it may never be touched
he's the offensive player of the year
while Lamar Jackson is the MVP eleisha
right - not winning the MVP right I
think I think I would vote for Michael
Thomas I would - I don't know if there's
anybody else out there that it's really
worthwhile of throwing into that
conversation McCaffrey is kind of
falling off nobody a degree it's a large
X know it's the question yeah Marv
Jackson or Michael - yeah I think you're
right and it's MVP and Offensive Player
of the Year so I'm with you I think I
think you're
exactly right Jameis Winston if he
didn't have our great production right
from and and he's the most exciting
offensive player you never know what the
hell is gonna have right but I think
it's Thomas or Lamar Jackson and and I
think that that Michael Tom and and it's
just a way to spray you know spread the
trophy yeah definitely they got it well
they the MVP who cares about often so
yeah right like if you have both of them
which one are you gonna display on the
man or which one you're gonna like stick
in the claws yeah stick an offensive
player of the year in the closet who
cares I was the MVP right whereas
Michael Thomas will have it front and
center on his mantle right well yeah
hopefully you're not putting it in the
closet either way but I got you it is
less important MVP special I mean that's
special you're in the lures of the NFL
forever all right the kids Chiefs
defense I know we're running out of time
here but another statement by them yeah
I'm gonna go with them and I know it's
obvious but I mean the last five games
by the Chiefs defense 17 9 16 3 & 3 I
mean those are the points they're
letting up they are playing phenomenal
football Steve Spagnola you've heard me
say that but they have some other elite
area secondaries playing good honey
badger as Rodney Harrison talked about
last night he's all over the field I
mean you don't know what he is he's
Safety's a nickel he's a corner he does
everything from them that way Chris
Jones is a grain breaker Frank Clark has
been playing a little bit better lately
they got size up run I think with all
those things and then Spagnola is good
game planning that's where I look at the
Chiefs as being more dangerous than than
ever and I really think they're still
kind of you know sliding under the radar
right now in the AFC
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports